welcome back to the rockstars one
division just gave us a groundbreaking
cameo to end the episode but they also
teased
an even more mysterious newcomer who is
monica rambo's engineer friend
and was that fifth year of college worth
it i'm eric voss
here with me to go rogue on this theory
are
uh is a wonderful panel that i'm so
excited to go
freaking nerdy with starting with uh
comedian and writer shawn distant
welcome back buddy eric
how are you hello um hello again to
grogu hey grogu what's that on your ear
is that a tiger why is there a tiger
here
what's with the tiger eric i think it
means agnes is spying on this
conversation so
careful what do you say about her i'll
turn the tiger away from me
very afraid earmuffs on the tiger uh
also with us friend of the show and
streamer angelica trey
welcome back hey thank you for having me
it's good being here i feel like i
should show something cool now i have a
sweater
oh let's go all right oh
how very sword very
very uh appropriate because you know
sentient weapon
uh whatever observation response
division over there in a tree
square we also are thrilled to have back
our buddy comedian writer erica wusu
hey everybody hey boss uh happy new year
it's not too late to say that is it
never
never too late and my cool random thing
that's sitting nearby this
black sketchbook so yeah happy black
history month how about that
oh we're gonna ask you to show us show
us your sketches
i can show you a schedule flip through
some things with some non-pornographic
drawings
we'll get to the porn later this episode
my nerdy stuff
oh
yes those are my samples that is a
hundred dollar sketch okay
all right all right let's talk about
this mystery coming out of wanda vision
episode five this
mystery aerospace engineer so while
describing the vehicle that monica wants
to build
to uh penetrate the west view barrier
she mentions this aerospace engineer
with a little smile that she knows can
help them and then proceeds to text this
person
we get a close-up of her hand texting
this but we don't see who she's texting
it's definitely a mystery that
wandavision is setting up
um maybe it'll be revealed at the end of
the season maybe next episode maybe you
know already but we know from promo
footage that this vehicle does
eventually get built
we can assume that this engineer is
going to show up at some point to help
many uh minds immediately jump to reed
richards mr fantastic
of the fantastic four given episode
four's mention of sword astronauts who
went missing however
various international subtitles for this
episode identified this mystery engineer
as
female yes gendered language giving us
the
giving us the huge easter egg what a
scoop what a scoop you can learn a lot
you know from from
uh translating the subtitles and i
thought that was so fascinating
i thought that was so fascinating so
based on that my thinking
was that it was monica rambo's squirrel
friend
from the inning of captain marvel the
scroll daughter of talos and soren
just because there seemed to be a
budding friendship there and we're gonna
know what that evolved into
um and we did know in episode four
monica defended those extraterrestrials
as
allies to hayward in episode four
suggesting that you know she might have
some friends up there from the stars
and reminding us that that uh
companionship might exist
and that uh crafty aerospace engineer
could be here because scrolls you know
as extraterrestrials know how to build
technology uh pretty well uh we know
that the squirrels were working on that
lightspeed engine
from uh captain marvel so yeah she knows
how to build stuff
so what do you guys think about this do
you think that was the squirrel person
or do you think this engineer could be
someone else that the mcu is trying to
connect to
eric i think the scroll is a excellent
theory
or an excellent theory but hear me out
what if it's shuri of wakanda she's
super smart
amazing engineer she's an everything
engineer i wouldn't just say a space
like she has
all of it you know what i mean yeah also
because uh she was the last person to
work on vision
you know in wakanda trying to remove the
stone from his forehead uh back in
infinity war
such you know she already has knowledge
of how to
handle and finesse infinity stone
technology and so could figure out a way
to penetrate the barrier that's
created by wanda's powers exactly she's
experienced
she's basically an expert in this would
be would we be saying this like tank
thing is made out of vibranium or like
here's the thing i was looking at the
sort of tiny image of that thing going
into the
barrier and the little inside of it kind
of reminded me of the inside of the
ant-man and wasp like little thing that
they used to go into the um
what was it the micro verse or the uh
you know
the quantum realm um to me it kind of
looked so i'm like what if it's
okay what if like out of left field what
if it's like ghost what if it's that
what if it's the girl who was like
phasing and is like
was raised by i guess uh
who's laurence fishburne's character and
like
i don't know there was something about
the build of it that kind of looked and
if we're talking about like
something that needs to be able to
absorb a lot of energy
and be able to like travel through
barriers like i wonder if it's someone
from the ant-man and the wasp movie in
general just because it kind of reminded
me of that same sort of shape
interesting theory yeah i mean that is
kind of an unanswered question from
ant-man the wasp right like whatever
happened to bill foster
and ghost uh hannah joe caiman's
character um
yeah like they just kind of scampered
off
could they be a lot of people are saying
they might be part of the
jimmy who's missing person right like
that he had this uh witness protection
person
maybe uh bill foster who was uh you know
working with her
ghost was kind of a criminal but like
was also kind of
seemingly on the same side as uh the
pims and the van dynes at the end there
like yeah maybe there is something with
that um yeah and the technology
quantum technology seems to be uh tied
in with you know
everything seems to be quantum in the
mcu right you're just like you know
quantum or from the big bang we can all
connect everything
but you know honestly eric i do feel
like the scroll
this girlfriend as you described her as
earlier girlfriend
um i think that's probably that to me
feels like the
easiest answer and like a maybe fun way
to do it would be in the episode like
have just a person show up and be like
they helped us build it you know and
it's just character and then at the end
you see a little shift from like you
know from human to scroll and to me that
feels like
maybe monica rambo and these skrulls are
all
this is like a little set up for the
secret invasion show that
i think they're doing with with uh nick
fury right
that feels like the cleanest answer but
there's also some wilder ones you know
like we'll get to some of the other
options i would say the argument against
scroll
is that jimmy wu put scrolls as a person
possibly behind the west view anomaly on
his board
so if squirrels were like part of their
operation we're friends of theirs why
would they be like those dirty scrolls
are trying to
pull tricks on us like i don't think
they'd be like dude my cubicle's right
over here
come on like would it be would it be i
mean maybe that's what's interesting
about
monica rambo is that she's the only one
that knows about these scrolls within
and like maybe they bring her in as
disguised as just an aerospace engineer
and then at the end jimmy wu
kind of catches a little like oh is she
a scroll and then we bring jimmy wu into
this like
x-files hunting down scrolls yeah maybe
maybe like monica or monica's mother
maria
was the previous was the founder of
sword uh and she had this secret side
division of sword that was scrolls and
that's what nick fury jumped to at the
end they had the space station
that was kind of like an insider secret
that did not get passed down to hayward
and that's why hayward's being like
there's other stuff here that people
aren't telling me why didn't i get
totally briefed and monica's like
i should have gotten this position
because i don't know if i can trust you
uh to tell you that you know we're we're
working with shape shifters up in the
you know what nick fury has proven that
they use scrolls in place of people
you know what i mean like nick fury has
used scrolls in his stead
hidden so i wouldn't put that past the
founders of sword and maybe that's like
because i do think sword is going to be
a huge part of the secret invasion show
so why not
i mean who else is there who's like the
craziest who would you think eric is
like the craziest answer from like
absolute left field because like i've
heard some crazy answers i don't know
about fantastic four really just because
it feels like too small of an internet
easiest
craziest i would say is uh a rocket's
old squeeze
lila you know the honor
right like he's an engineer she's an
engineer
uh if like you know the high
evolutionary we did get a tease of
bova the the cow nurse from uh
episode two animated intro high
evolutionary created bova
also created rocket and lila so that
would be
if you asked me crazy i got a crazy
answer for you i think there are a few
more grounded answers
like let's talk about riri williams
dominique thorne is coming to the mcu
and an iron heart rio williams is an mit
student i speculated could have been in
the crowd in civil war when uh tony
stark gave a grant
to all the mit students and that's could
be like you know she's gonna be tied
into armor wars and iron heart
uh do we think like uh monica rambo's
friend is uh riri williams
could be i mean it's going to tie in
more of that young avengers feel
woo i want to bring you in on this uh do
you think it's more likely to be riri
williams or a skrull
or uh shuri i really do think shuri but
it could
absolutely be any of them it could be
the squirrel friend who
they could do a misdirect and introduce
them as riri and then for whatever
reason at the end of the season
shape-shift back into a sprawl but
another off-the-wall idea i had
as a potential female big brain in the
mcu
jane foster uh who will probably
become lady thor uh at some point
because we already have kat denning's
character in the show
uh helping you know she's really into
the sitcom
uh developments in one division's world
so that would be a fun way to introduce
her before
she you know makes her appearance in 4
11 lightning and thunder
thunder
i mean that would be a huge i would say
that would be a huge like
actor that maybe paul bettany was like i
got to work with
uh jane foster you know like i like yeah
i'd be surprised natalie portman yeah i
mean natalie portman uh it's coming back
in the mcu a fascinating take there
because here's the deal she is a
an astrophysicist darcy lewis has gotten
her doctorate suggesting that she did
not blip
you need five years to get to work on
that thesis you know
but uh we know jane foster did uh she
did disappear in the snap
um but uh you know the idea that she
would be an aerospace engineer as well
yeah definitely they all had to work on
that
equipment and learn how to wire and
solder to put that stuff together
i can imagine uh jane foster getting a
little dirty and greasy
working with some wrenches and some
welding material
uh think we'd all like to see that yeah
yeah
i mean regarding riri williams i i would
say
it's interesting to me when they cast
people and how early they cast them
like yeah mahersha ali they've cast so
early in this process that you know he's
going to show up in something early i
feel like
and it's similar for ironheart like it
seems like
they've cast this actress before
other things are known about the show
and it's like maybe it's because you're
going to maybe see
her show up in in something like one
division or
in my head i kind of thought she'd be in
falcon winter soldier
but maybe she's in both you know it's
possible yeah i would say if it's not uh
squirrels because girls are like
engineers as well like the next like uh
prominent female engineer to me is riri
williams uh
shuri absolutely is a scientist i see
her as like she's a princess who
is super smart and uh like oversees a
team
of like uh weapons builders and tech
builders she's kind of like the cue
uh james bond q of the mcu whereas riri
is someone who's like
she's got a wrench she's under a car you
know she
is like truly building [ __ ] like she to
me is like
aerospace engineer but i'm gonna throw
this other idea at you guys
so if it's not reed richards right what
if it is sue storm
but what if monica rambo is being set up
to be the invisible woman the sous storm
figure they're going to completely do
something
different and new with a fantastic boar
yeah so the michael b jordan casting
yeah
you know that's interesting it would
explain that scan when they sort of
tried to like scan her
right right that's really interesting
like it would say we're not going to
make her photon or spectrum that was
just kind of a misdirect she's going to
be
the sue storm of this ensuite would
people be too pissed off at that
i needed to be sue storm who's the
invisible woman
i mean would it be would she be attached
to a family though like i mean is there
a
is who would be the reed richards like
would she have a brother
yeah like is it a sing is it like a
individual we just get sue storm or do
we get
all four of them that'd be really
interesting i don't know it'd be a real
surprise
i am just speculating out here because i
i honestly at the end of the day i feel
like uh
kevin feige and john watts probably feel
pretty precious about
uh the fantastic four and wanting to do
it right and pure as much as they can
not to say it's gonna be like four white
people and a family i
you know i think they're gonna be you
know approach this in a more common
sense an interesting way
but i think they're uh i don't think
it's they're gonna change the names of
the characters and
and merge them and retcon them with
other characters i just threw that
curveball out there
just so people start freaking out in the
comments i mean everyone's panic in the
comments
it would be it would be wild you know
and i
i do think what i like about this show
so far is the unpredictability like
you know evan peter showing up at the
end it did kind of
i kind of knew he was going to be on the
show i guess i had heard but like it
still surprised me so
i'm excited that the show still could
surprise so i don't know
those big surprises could maybe happen
you know i'm excited to see some more
x-men
in there so some great theories that
were proposed here um
angelica you are getting a golden
sparkle bug for coming out there first
with uh the hot take of shuri
uh because yeah i totally think you
would love to see and you know what
here's some
uh something to point out wakanda has
some explaining to do
for how the remains of vision ended up
in the hands of sword
right like shuri had uh dusted we saw
her name on on a vanish board
but so she wasn't there to okay that but
vision was made of vibranium partially
right so like why would they be okay
with letting sword take his remains
uh they're kind of like the superior uh
nation on earth like why would they let
an inferior
unstable world power like the united
states just had shield be corrupted by
hydra
why would wakanda be like sure sword you
can take the body
hell no they wouldn't let that happen i
think you're right and but also with
wakanda it's also like they have this
period where t'challa and
was gone like that five-year period we
don't know what happened in wakanda and
it'd be really interesting
to see sort of a blip like in the way we
saw monica rambo in that first scene
coming back in the hospital what
happened in wakanda it'd be fascinating
a lot has changed everyone's grown
yeah the world's different yeah and then
also
wakanda had just joined the world at the
end of black panther but before infinity
war
so there could have been a working
relationship with the us government or
with
sword and shield so that maybe something
that finagled there
where they were like all right you can
take vision but let us get our starbucks
all right so i love bringing it jane
foster i didn't think about her so
i'm giving you a point for that as well
but uh sean i am also giving you a point
i think you had a pretty strong argument
there for how scrolls could work
and for how like riri williams could
look in this universe so
i i think you have a strong take on that
as well uh this is still rogue theory
i'm still rewarding points for who makes
the best cases and who makes the best
argument
because i'm a freak and i award points
to subtract points
when i'm just talking about i'm feeling
that competition now
that's right i'm gonna start foaming
sean you're also getting a point for
that as well so you get two points sean
for
for ghost uh as well forget about ghost
she might have disappeared but she's
still in her hearts
all right so we have uh more things we
want to talk about specifically a lot of
you guys have pointed out there was an
alarm a breach alarm
blaring at the end of episode five so
we're going to talk about what that
alarm meant
but first we want to thank some people
who helped us make this episode uh
starting with our friends at blue chew
so blue chew is making waves and
bringing more confidence to the bedroom
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
a chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost blue chew
tablets combat
all forms of ed and help men gain that
extra confidence
when it is time to perform blue chew is
an online prescription service so no
visits to the doctor's office no waiting
in line at the pharmacy
it ships right to your door and in a
discreet package
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days
blue chews licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient and strength for your
prescription
don't like swallowing pills no problems
here bluetooth tablets are
chewable bluetooth tablets are made in
the usa and it's cheaper than a pharmacy
so if you could benefit from
extra confidence when it's time to
perform visit bluechew.com for more
details
and important safety information and
we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free
when you use our promo code rogue at
checkout just pay the five dollars of
shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code rogue
r-o-g-u-e
to receive your first month for free and
we thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode
we also want to thank our friends at
expressvpn for sponsoring rogue theory
so nobody likes someone peeping on them
when they're in the shower or having a
private moment
so why would you let people look in on
you when you go online you freak
exhibitionist
you know what that does make you a freak
we don't kink shame here if you're an
exhibitionist
whatever gets you off we're we we we're
okay with it as long as it's safe and
legal
um this went to a very weird place for
that reason it's okay i followed you
there yeah
do you know what i don't want people
watching me they don't want people
watching me surf in the web
exactly uh you know what sometimes you
do and say weird
creepy gross things online and that's
not any of the government's business
uh and sometimes people will try to use
that and sell it to you know hackers to
you know
steal your stuff well this is why you
need expressvpn so your internet service
provider knows every single website you
visit
and they can sell this information to ad
companies tech giants who will use your
data to target you
while expressvpn puts a stop to that it
creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so that your online
activity
cannot be seen by anyone i use
expressvpn on all my devices it works on
phones laptops even routers
so everyone who shares your wi-fi
including the the deadbeat sitting in
the car outside
they can be protected even when they
don't have expressvpn on their
individual device
and the best part is using expressvpn is
as easy as closing the bathroom door you
just fire up the app you click one
button and you're protected
expressvpn is the world's number one
rated vpn by cnet wired and the verge
and countless others
so if you're like me and you believe
your online activity is your business
alone
secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com
rogue today use my exclusive link
p r e s s vpn dot com slash rogue and
you can get an extra three months for
free
that's expressvpn.com rogue and finally
new rockstars is excited to be
partnering with the app stereo on three
new weekly live shows all three shows
are
live on the stereo app which you can
download for free at stereo.com
new rockstars this is like a podcast app
but it's live you send in your
voicemails we play them
on the episode live we react to in real
time so you can kind of call us out or
pick our brains live
it's super interactive it's great uh so
these three shows so on mondays our
editors are dissecting some of their
favorite moments from our week of videos
those are editors john and josh
super funny dudes uh you definitely want
to tune that on wednesdays it's philip
molina and i
going through the week of entertainment
news on new rockstars news and then on
friday jessica clemons and i do a live
inside marvel
one division after show we simulcast it
so you guys can get it as early as
possible after the episode drops
8 a.m pacific uh and that's hours before
it drops on youtube
and after that show jessica and i stick
around and answer some stereo exclusive
questions
last week we had over a thousand
comments submitted and we got through as
many of them as we could
a lot of people had some really strong
feelings about quicksilver ringing that
doorbell we'd love to hear from you so
you can access all these live shows
share your questions and theories
interact with us in real time by
downloading the free stereo app
at stereo dot com new rockstars again
that's stereo dot com slash new
rockstars
okay back to one division you three
right after wanda and vision hear their
doorbell ring and uh she goes to answer
the door
we cut to darcy at the sword base and
there is a
breach alarm going off this is the same
breech alarm that was previously going
off
when wanda was leaving westview to throw
that stark industry's
drone back at them and said boom you're
looking for this
um so that means someone is going in or
out of that border
so let's talk about this who do we think
set off that alarm
was it pietro coming in from the outside
uh was someone else trying to leave what
do you guys think i didn't
you know it's interesting because i
rewatched the scene where where she came
out
of to throw the drone back at them and
it felt like that alarm was going off
long before she got to the border and
walked through it and
the way i was sort of interpreting the
alarm
was like energy surge you know like
like i was you know i it definitely
could be someone coming in or out for
sure but
in the way it presented in the episode i
felt like it was some sort of energy
surge and they've talked about the
border being important so i don't know
is the border moving
is you know is it getting bigger or is
there
you know when she like turned the whole
thing red i don't know
so sean do you think the moment she
turned it red it was just setting off
that alarm the whole time they're like
we can't turn off this fire alarm what
are we supposed to do
on top of that because i was thinking
something similar to where maybe it's
not necessarily a breach
but rather it's some sort of like
change in it so who knows if wanda
is setting this off just to like keep
them on their toes or maybe
it is in tune with her emotions
right like her powers it's in tune with
her emotions so after that doorbell ring
this was going off because she could
send something is wrong and therefore it
was setting off that alarm ah
that would make sense with the drone
right if she sees the drone and her eyes
light up and the alarm starts going off
it's because she's using her powers in a
way where she feels threatened or
something like i could see
that that'd be really interesting um but
let's assume
yeah i think that is a totally valid way
to read what was going on i don't think
it necessarily means someone was
escaping or leaving in that moment but
let's assume that maybe someone did
breach it
i personally don't think it was pietro
coming in from the outside
i think whatever we're seeing of evan
peters here is something from within the
anomaly
or the way the anomaly is kind of a
pocket to uh
the another dimension like from the
multiverse maybe that's how they got
evan peters in there
um or it's someone using that image to
try to deceive wanda whatever your take
is there
uh so i'm thinking if there is someone
entering or exiting
especially after wanda turned that
border wall red red red
maybe that beekeeper finally got the
[ __ ] out of there he's like
i'm still alive she's distracted they're
arguing i'm running
if um because we know um a future
episode either episode six or seven
kids are finally gonna be in west view
for this halloween episode
after vision's like why aren't there
kids here do we think wanda might have
been like okay fine kids and she sucked
in a bunch of kids back into this
reality
and that's the breach that's terrifying
oh yeah i don't feel like wanda would do
that though because she's already
brought in so many
like she brought in a limited amount of
people but i i truly
think that as angry and in anguish
um you know that she is i don't think
she's going to suck in children
i i just okay you tell me
ethics it would explain sort of the
clips of vision walking through the
street really confused like
what is going on with all these kids you
know and she is the scarlet
witch and witches do like snatching up
kids which is
our evil um we ain't trying to like
really we're not trying to like
make any stereotypes or anything but we
know that which is like
children okay they're interesting she's
kind of chaotic neutral
so i could see that and they clearly
explain that but i just
i just don't think she's gonna bring in
real life
children well i just want to know where
those kids come from then because we see
them in the promo footage they're our
kids
shrink down a bunch of adults and a kid
and the kids can sort of age themselves
there's something going on there
i you know eric when you said like maybe
evan peters is coming you know maybe
she's accessing the multiverse and
pulling him out of the x-men universe
like i wonder if that could be the
breach in itself is like they have tabs
on all the people that are there
and now a new entity has shown up
where an alarm goes off and it's like
wait who is this and maybe we'll see
the confusion of sword next episode like
where did this guy come from
you know and maybe maybe it is maybe
it's not like breaching the border but
just breaching the universe
you know so what we're seeing is there
is a
um a membrane between west view and the
outside world where sword is but there's
a
separate backdoor that leads to
other dimensions and now i'm curious
where in west view
is that hidden door that goes down to
hell or goes down to
the fox's franchise uh i'm dying to know
it's the magic box
from the magic act oh yeah oh angelica
you are all over it and speaking of the
magic show
i think the alarm got set off by maybe
vision trying to find his way out
because in that episode he's really like
what's going on
what are you not telling me so it could
be that he was
he like had his hand to the the membrane
coming in and out like the wall and like
he sensed pietro and heard the doorbell
so he like
you know zoomed back to the house
because remember pietro
she opened the door and then vision came
in like who's at the door so it could
have been vision
trying to make his way out and trying to
discover like what's going on are you
saying
vision is out quicksilvering quicksilver
in his own
introduction that would be a flex it
would be a great place
because like really they just cut away
from paul bettany for like maybe
18 seconds and then is he gonna be like
wanda
who is this
he can fly through walls he can fly
really fast
he could have done it evan peters did
say who is that out of breath popsicle
right didn't he say that
all right here's how i'm gonna award
points uh angelica you did
or you didn't have me right away with
saying she the kids but yeah i think
it's a valid way to go so you get one
point for that
and also the idea that this uh extra
door could have been
from the magic vanishing cabinet uh but
sean that was your idea saying that
there is a
another breach to another dimension and
that's what the breach alarm is
uh i like this idea that you tied it to
the chicken being rewound into eggs
uh so you get a point for that but
you're also getting a point for
uh what you just said which was that
vision
uh just quickly darted off the screen
real quick
out
and then we see like a 19 like a 2000s
confessional where vision's like
i wasn't fast enough
okay so i believe that ties us up at
three sparkle box for
each of you so it's anyone's game as we
head into
rogue questions holy [ __ ] oh my
god here's our question in the recently
released photos of jared leto's joker
from the upcoming snyder cut of justice
league
the character no longer has his
signature face tattoos he ain't damaged
no more
so i want to know from you guys what is
the in-universe reason
for joker getting his tattoos removed in
the snyder cut
i think because also he has long hair in
those pictures so
and he had his like slicked back hair in
suicide squad so i think
it could be do you guys remember in the
dark night when
joker kind of painted his face peach to
look like a regular kind of like dude
yeah when they tried to assassinate
gordon right
so i think something like that could
have happened before this jared leto
joker was apprehended
in the justice league snyder cut uh yeah
i think he tried to
go undercover a little bit to go do some
sort of mischief
in gotham or wherever and and then he
was apprehended
maybe by batman maybe by amanda waller
everyone's so happy they're like they
got rid of the damage tattoo
then in in justice league there's gonna
be the triumphant wash off and the
i'm still damaged baby
people can't wait for them
didn't go peach i think he just washed
off his makeup and then that was just a
skin
whereas it was jack nicholson who had
his taste bleach
and turned into it i gotta give you a
correction
but i think in the photo
it looked like he had like a butcher's
uniform on or something like he looked
it was kind of a weird apron that he had
he had like a weird
apron on and to me i was just like yeah
you know what the joker he's going clean
he wanted to get a blue collar every day
job so he went to the
to the tattoo removal place and he just
was like i made a huge mistake
sometimes the joker if he's all about
chaos there are times where he's all
about order and right now
he wants to work in a butcher shop and
we're gonna see him sort of like
come out of his like uh like uh haze of
being a normal joker into crazy joker
and maybe read
and then to your point eric he redraws
it on his head by the end of the
justice league what if the tattoos
were a joke all along
they were temporary tattoos they take
them off to show he's serious now
yeah that's part of the the joker act so
he wasn't really damaged
yeah in the comics he does sometimes
have the gun that
shoots bullets sometimes but then
sometimes shoots the bang
it's a joke he wipes them off and he's
like i fooled you
well okay i'll combine our theories
angelica and say that
he had the fake tattoos so he had all
these identifying things for the cops
and then when he wants to go undercover
he just washes him off and goes to work
at the butcher
well she's combining for combining
everyone's theories
in that it just did way i think i gotta
give you the point
uh even though everyone did kind of
contribute to that everyone gets a point
for that
but for knowing that the american way is
putting two together to get for
sean you get the point
making sean the winner of today's
episode of rogue theory well done sean
i share my win with my comrades who
bro who dragged me across the finish
line as um
but so you can you can steal
you can steal this win by showing us
some pornographic drawings from your
sketchbook
you have
[Music]
oh
news yeah i got it we want to see woo's
deviantart page
and we want it now you can paint
spiderman like one of your french girls
spider gwen drawing him like one of her
little french girls
i like that i like that idea hey well
that is it for this episode of rogue
theory
thank you so much to our guests sean
distant angelica trey
and eric wusu follow all three of them
on all social media platforms support
their projects show them some love
say nice things to them because all
three are great and working on
incredible things and we're so lucky to
have them here with us at new rockstars
now you can support our channel by
checking out one of our many great merch
options so i'm wearing our unusual
couples shirt
it's got secret ar easter eggs that are
awesome but they got all kinds of
options we got this hat that i wear all
the time
it's like my new favorite hat i've never
had a hat that fits my huge
dumb egghead and now i got one so
yeah and that's the way you can support
us directly so find that at new
rockstarsmerch.com
and yeah you can follow me at eavos on
all social stuff follow the rockstar
subscribe here on youtube
and a reminder to download the stereo
app by going to stereo dot com
new rockstar so you can check out these
three new weekly live shows
you can find it for free on apple and
android create an avatar and profile
and be sure to download now so that you
can submit questions to one of our
upcoming shows
tomorrow morning 8 a.m pacific you'll be
able to hear me and jessica clements
talking about
episode six of wanda vision you'll be
able to get that hours before it comes
out on youtube so if you're
super eager if you're super thirsty get
up bright and early if you're on the
east coast it's 11 a.m you can handle
that anyway uh
we'll see you all next time boners
[Music]
you